California State University Northridge (CSUN) Professor and Author Eric Edson: The love interest...now this is outside of
hero and adversary I believe the
love interest character is the most
fascinating of the rest of the character
categories because it's so replete with
emotion and a way to explore the nature
of the hero what is right with them and
what is hurting them and what is wrong
with them to the love interest creates a
subplot or a main plot and drive story
change and humanizes the hero there's
you know through these through intimate
emotions but it's about mate bonding
with a love interest character that's
what it is and there is a way to tell I
think this is important to know because
a lot of people get confused about love
interest characters whether they're Co
heroes or or you know what is their
place in the story there is a way to
know whether a love interest character
is a subplot or the main plot and it's
this if you took a love interest
character and that relationship out of
the movie would you still have a story
that's how you do it and sometimes we're
going to see yeah when I have some
examples here lined up you'll see what I
mean
but that's important to know Drive story
change works alternate leaf for and
against the hero remember every
character category isn't only about
helping the hero there has to be
challenge and there has to be conflict
too for it to work the love interest
character works alternately for and
against the hero and the issue of a love
interest character with the hero who are
here whoever he or she is the love
interest character adds tension
and a conflict going on under the
surface of things
because that plot is about in fact mate
bonding which is in fact about sexual
conquests now I'm stating it bluntly to
make the point I mean there's a lot of
wiggle room there and using this plot or
subplot you can do it
from the very very gentle and and and
hardly hinting at sexuality at all to
the incredibly steamy and everything
everything in between and that of course
depends on you and it depends on the
story you're trying to write you get
your choice but the thing is it is there
and once you have tension between
people it is a universal thing every
nation every language humanity gets what
that is I mean would you we are we are
sensual creatures and therefore you are
offering up emotion that is
international in scope and you can use
that for character growth purposes for
challenges of personality and how people
must grow and all that kind of stuff it
is you it is the well of what you want
screenwriting and visual storytelling to
be which is the pursuit of emotion it's
just it's amazing it works very well and
it also pushes the hero into character
growth ah and yes people sometimes get
this wrong if a couple is married at the
beginning of the of the of the film
above your story and with some ups and
downs whatever you know but they stay
married and they are reasonably happy
together all the way through the movie
into the end that is not a love interest
character it has to be about this back
and forth back and forth opposing and
and then helping and opening
a couple of examples of that yeah there
are 2 mm Apollo movies that have come
out actually three lately but the two
that I'm thinking of are Apollo 13 which
goes back a ways and the one the latest
one which was overlooked by everybody
which is really tragic because I thought
it was really I've seen it three times
now and it's just riveting and it's
first man it was the true rendition of
the true story of both what's-his-name
the first
Armstrong Neil Armstrong but Neil
Armstrong is married and in Apollo 13
Tom Hanks is married to and the married
spouse at home becomes that category of
character that they turn into is the
endangered innocent not a love interest
they become the goal of those two
astronauts they are going through all of
this and all they want to do you know
for all the better you know the problems
that come up and the possibilities of
dying that come up they want to surmount
all that so that they can get back to
earth and save that endangered innocent
from the metaphorical death that she
would also be experiencing if he were to
die in space that is endangered innocent
plot and that is not a love interest
plot okay here's some example
Neytiri where is she wait a minute here
she is in in Avatar
Oh again what a what a wonderful
relationship in that picture and this I
ask you she's also doing a whole lot of
mentor duties again but with overlaid
with sexual tension because that's key
to that relationship it just is and
elevates it if you take a net-net eerie
out of
do you still have a movie yeah you do
which means Neytiri is a love interest
subplot it is not the main plot although
she you know and she is there and it's
big and it's important in all that stuff
but all the same it is a subplot it is
not the primary goal alright
officer rhoads in bridesmaids that's
easier to see and to be able to say you
know if you took him out of it could you
still have a movie yes you could
that's a subplot Lisa McDowell in Coming
to America if you removed her from
coming to America would you still have a
movie you sure yeah
yeah no yeah that's it this is it not
fair I'm going back too far here I'm
going back too far you would not because
she is the heroes got the Eddie Murphy
the prince she is his goal he goes to
America to find a woman that he can fall
in love with and marry and not have to
marry the the woman that he knows
nothing about and really doesn't care
about back home that the king his father
has chosen for him
she is the goal therefore she is a love
interest character who also provides
there's a double role here we won't talk
about it tonight but the love interest
who is the main goal also is plays
adversary they are each other's
adversary and love interest
simultaneously that's why it works
differently and we'll talk about that
another time
Alicia Nash in A Beautiful Mind if you
take her out what yes it would be
crushing Lee less interesting and very
diminished but yes you could you could
remove her and you would still have the
man struggling to come back from madness
and making it yes so that is
when one of the character categories
gets played by a movie star and it is
big I mean it takes a lot of screen time
and it's really important to things but
it is still a subplot in its way that is
called a charismatic whatever a
charismatic mentor or a charismatic love
interest they get a lot of screen time
but at their core they are still feeling
filling the functions of these sub
categories
Georgia Coors June Carter how about June
Carter and Johnny Cash if you took June
Carter out of there would there still be
a movie what does he want
throughout he wants Jude Carter even
more than he wants to be famous as a
singer he wants her yeah she is
the love interest adversary for that
film and so forth okay you get the idea
now then this example I've chosen for a
love interest character this is Carol
the waitress in as good as it gets this
one had me stumped for a while when I
first sat down to analyze it I thought
it was a three hero movie and then I
went through it once and I said no that
doesn't work and I took a harder look at
it this is a one hero movie Melvin Udall
is the hero because it is Melvin who
wants Carol she never until you know at
certain points toward the end expresses
really any romantic interest in this
poor man who is trapped in being a jerk
you know because of the nature of how he
defends himself against all emotion but
the beauty of the profession that has
been assigned to him which is a very
successful romance novel writer I mean
it's just it's perfect you know that is
the true him screaming to get out you
know that kind of thing it's I think
it's a wonderful wonderful story
wonderfully written but okay I mean at
this point and this is as part of a
midpoint sequence
Carol her son I believe it's asthma he's
got asthma really bad the kind that
under certain conditions the kid could
die from and he had a really bad attack
and she got all panicked and she's a
waitress who waits on on Melvin every
morning and how many of you have seen
this okay most okay cool
good then you get it and then after a
heat Belvin sends a top-flight
top-dollar doctor to her apartment to to
see the boy and yes and he writes
prescriptions and he's telling her you
know it's gonna be okay we're gonna
bring him back and he knows how to do it
and she's been getting you know crap
advice from these you know bad cheap
programs healthy health care programs
that she's had Carol couldn't afford the
doctor for her sick son so Melvin got
her a very high-end one and in the
middle of the night she's got up she
sleeps on the couch and she pulled on
her jeans she has to tell
Melvin something she is burning with the
need to tell Mel than something and she
runs out to get to his place in the
night in the middle of the night
that's how urgent this is for her and
that's telling us something right there
well it happens to be raining that night
and she also gets soaked so she's
dripping soaking wet by the time she
gets to Melvin's apartment building and
of course Melvin is very well off and
the apartment is very upscale so here
she is and she's coming up to his front
door this is a comedy this is a romantic
comedy and this whole thing is setting
it up this way especially what she's
going to be telling him be that she has
to tell him face by face that this the
rain is accentuating a sensuality in her
that she is about to deny and it's
perfect as a juxtaposition so
she knocks it's me yeah and Melvin lives
alone self-created isolation no one can
stand him early on I guess it's the it's
the next-door neighbour Simon Says - who
says - Melvin you are a horror of a
human being I mean that's the general
attitude that he has created out there
in the world and then he hears my
goodness it's Carol the waitress he yes
he wants her to wait on him every day
when he goes for breakfast because she's
the only one who will wait on him you
know cuz she can give guff as good as
she gets it from this guy but he has
stronger feelings I mean he's of an age
he's desperate he's gotta break out of
his prison and he knows that and he's
drawn to her and one of the reasons
Melvin is sympathetic is we like her too
I mean she's a genuine human being she's
a terrific lady and you can tell by you
know caring for her son you know and she
he's making a good choice here and
therefore we're kind of rooting for him
in strange ways okay but because of his
OCD he has insufferable all he is
insufferable always cracking wise with
sharp put-downs for everyone and she
says I'm sorry about the hour but I must
speak with you she hasn't opened the
door yet and now he opens the door
Melvin so opens the door and immediately
averts his eyes embarrassed at seeing
her t-shirt he was not expecting this
because for him you know the sensuality
there is a it's funny because and the
day the dial the scene is being played
and what's going on between them but
what is being done here by the writers
and by the director is they are playing
the element of sensuality and sexuality
and mate bonding conquest that is what
they are playing here romantic comedies
and romances all have to have something
insurmountable between the two Patel
lovers insurmountable and that's what
the story is about how they finally get
together in this case what is
insurmountable is Melvin's personality
okay and he's his eyes you know averts
are his eyes and so forth just glancing
at the t-shirt and she finally catches
up with it I mean she's cold she's wet
she wasn't thinking about that
boobs Carroll realizes the physical
picture she is unwittingly presenting
Melvin can't takes take his eyes from
wandering wandering a bit but he also
looks down and sees that she's sopping
wet
you know she's dripping all over the
floor all over the hallway for a guy
like Melvin you know he can't step on a
crack let alone stand watch somebody
standing there dripping all over
everything
Carol waits for Melvin to be polite and
offer her a bloody towel so he's
flummoxed at this point and so he's
gonna and he goes inside and he doesn't
know quite to do what quite to say and
he Melvin hates thank-yous again it's
part of his no emotion
he fights emotion at every turn
thank you contain emotion and he always
avoids roomy revealing emotion and yeah
that's his sarcastic nasty wit that's
another way he avoids emotion but he
says if you've come to thank me don't
don't I put it in a note he doesn't want
any emotion expressed face-to-face even
just in the thank you so he gets her a
towel there's another funny bit in there
we won't go there and Carol just has to
ask why did you do this for Spencer
that's her son and Melvin said I wanted
you to come back to the restaurant and
wait on me and she says do you have any
idea how odd that sounds but it's pure
Melvin too and we know that so he blurts
it so what have you come to tell me what
is this and there is one of the more
charming
elongated deathly silences between two
people now the awkward silence lingers
has come all this way and this cold in
the wet and she's trying to find the
words to say what she came to say and
it's not coming she really struggles
with it and on until she can finally
blurt it out all at once push it out and
say I will never sleep with you never
that's what woke her up in the middle of
the night and drove her through the rain
she was terrified worried that this is
why he did this and in truth that had
something to do with it we're about to
see that here too but also again a
relative to the sexual tension okay if
that's her a message that coulda waited
until you know next morning at the at
the cafe why this absolute burning
urgency you know there's something else
going on there all of Melvin's defenses
go up and he resorts to his self
protective cynical sharp tongue because
deep down that was what he was hoping or
thinking well we don't open for the
no- O's until 9:00 a.m. and again
yeah that's that's pure Melvin right and
again he's just being defensive and
obnoxious and that's how he gets
defensive and she's turns to go and she
mumbles I really mean it and he blurts
will you be at the restaurant to wait on
me tomorrow that's a very strange thing
to say and to go through all of this for
that and she says yes and she goes
there's that that's the same and next
this comes right next and this only is a
few seconds long we cut to a close-up of
his clock and then his slippers while
he's in bed now sleeping and mumbling to
himself hapis
never she says never and then he gets up
and he puts on his slippers and what is
happening here is perfect for a midpoint
sequence perfect the second step of
character growth which usually takes
place in hero goal sequence 12 is when
the hero undertakes a physical action
some sort of metaphoric physical action
to overcome what is stopping them and
clogging them emotionally inside and
that is exactly what Melvin does a man
who hates all pills gets up to take his
first anti obsessive-compulsive disorder
pill ever that is a huge thing for
Melvin so alright the love interest as
Carol and at the midpoint we understand
you know the kind of wacky rare and
wacky nature of that relationship
creates a subplot or main plot
absolutely drive story change and
humanizes the hero you bet works
alternately for and against the hero
yes throughout and in other ways she is
doing that add tension and a
conquest conflict remember that
can be just a small tone a mood it's not
you know nothing blatant or flagrant
necessarily and pushes the hero into
character growth he just took the pill
yes all of that is true of this
character I think it's a very unusual
love interest relationship with the hero
when you see the whole thing I think it
works marvelously okay sidekick